hi slugs happy valentine's day this week
you guys right now if you're watching
this on youtube please subscribe we want
to get to 200k subscribers i say this
year annie says this week so get us
there please hit subscribe if you
haven't yet and tell your friends to
whatever you need to do you guys i do
stand-up comedy we all do well kalila
doesn't but we're coming on the road and
i'm going to be in indianapolis march
17th i'm coming to philadelphia san
diego austin texas chicago and so much
more i also just added a show in new
york city february 25th get tickets at
estronice.com also that show doll face
that i shot all last summer comes out
this friday on hulu check it out yo what
up i love this crew this vibe it's been
amazing on the road you can come see me
again
i'm going to be on february 11th through
12th i will be in british columbia you
can see me the next weekend in las vegas
you can also see me in washington dc
after that and then in march i'll be in
richmond virginia san francisco
uh florida a bunch of dates coming up
just please look at annie letterman.com
shows
there should be ones almost every
weekend i'm coming to see you guys i
can't wait i keep looking at the wrong
camera but it doesn't matter
watch dollface
[Music]
today is the valentine's day episode of
trash tuesday
and we were told to wear red
and i ordered a dress off amazon that
was red and it
it was called amazon.com you told me
when you were high where'd you interview
amazon.com
and i'm done with you jeffrey bezos it's
just for like there's no way this looked
good in the thing i swear it did i'm
offended that you offered that to me
when i walked in
you're like klyla do you not want your
shoulders look at what you came in
wearing this says not your baby
that's me and that's mean to say i
borrowed it from jules i didn't have
anything right that's really mean to say
i'm validating i'm your baby i'm your
baby [ __ ] on valentine's day you know
valentine's day has never meant a lot to
me in terms of a lover's thing hell it's
always just been a friend's day for me
it's a day for us to really
deepen our friendship so this week why
don't we make valuables
how else are we going to deepen our
friendships let me see that badge again
let's make valentine's day about the
girls this year oh my god you're being
so cute esther got her makeup done she
can't stop glowing so i
no one has commented on my
red and first my this is kind of my
first date look
if i was was your first date in 1920
how old are these guys esther i just
want to know if you actually know how to
play scrabble
how
dare
you
and are you good at it i
am terrible at it but i obviously know
how to play i was in scrabble club in
junior high oh my god
we're getting banged out she was in
scrabble club wait that's true the years
do line up
but you're still bad at it
i am terrible you're actively getting
tmj no it's actually not fun to play it
at home because dave is so much better
at it than me that it's like i have to
that's that's why i pay carlos i'm the
person with the most words it's the
person with the most placements strategy
yeah that's what's annoying is it's all
about like being sneaky with a double
triple word scores like i have i'm bad
at strategy i'm good at it but i thought
you're very good at strategy actually
that's kind of your strong suit
[Laughter]
i'm triggered because you know i can't
read or spell
i have no clue what these things say
what do these squares say
double word score triple letter score so
i thought i would just
if this were my valentine's day date i
would wear a scrabble and did you tell
him
and would you tell him to put his tiles
on your body
wherever you like
but we know it'll be
on our back
[Laughter]
not to quote the great rick glassman but
we'd all be shocked if anyone [ __ ] you
face forward
i feel like this is the appropriate
outcome for a go-go queen wow
unsuspecting yeah seemingly you know
innocent sea men and scenes seemingly
innocent
i want to hear about this what's going
on here
i you know i searched the mall far and
wide i said i'll come up with the
greatest i always know when it's the
outfit you are single-handedly keeping
malls in business across america guys
i'm a mob [ __ ] okay my boyfriend calls
me the cutest girl of the mall that's
our thing i love it i every comedy club
i've done in the past
27 years has been in a mall it's
so fun the edmonton one oh boy was that
crazy now i was pissed to go to edmonton
i was like well you facetimed me and i
was really upset because i was like what
themed room did they put you in annie i
know and i was like it's funny you know
this that i've been disrespected so the
edmonton uh club is in a it's in this
huge mall it's like the mall of america
but it's the canadian version so they
have a they have a wave pool they have
like there's people in swimsuits at the
mall in the dead of the winter like fake
way i was like speaking of fake waves
nobody's wearing their masks
but um they have like bobby was telling
me like and it's so funny because i
didn't even know there's like this whole
pond and there's some attraction in the
middle of the pond and you can ride
those little like swan
things with petal things over to in the
mom in the mall have you been here with
bobby but i didn't know what was the
attraction until i talked to bobby and
you and bobby said that it's seals that
you can hear screaming for screeching
for their lives at night in the dead of
the night because you're hanging out at
the mall at night when it's closed
because you the hotel
is in the mall not that that's where we
stay stalkers they have like sad like
sea mammals in there
imagine being a steel and being like i
live in the edmonton mall imagine not
being a seal that lives in a mall esther
yeah i'm gonna say i pretty much know
what that's like but they have themed
rooms in that hotel i walk in i'm mad at
my agent i walk in there's a [ __ ] hot
tub in the middle of my
right and i go and i was mad at him
literally for sending me somewhere
during winter i was like it's snowing
but i didn't know that my whole life was
to be inside a mall for the whole
weekend
so there's this giant jacuzzi and i'm
like [ __ ] this is [ __ ] awesome and
then i go downstairs and i realize that
it's i see all these posters for like
themed rooms and i realize i got like
the shittiest room you can get at the
fantasy no way they have like they have
a um
a trucker room which i was really that
was the one i wanted
um they have a roman room with like
pillars and the beds like a circle in
the middle of the room
they have i'm literally going to call my
agent today did not get one
i did not get a themed room so then i
asked the guy and what was one of the
other ones was um they had like a
hollywood one room they have a holiday
and so i go i go can i i was like can i
get a themed room and he's like i'll
check on it
and he goes no they only had the truck
room and it was 450 bucks and i was like
and
didn't get it for me i was like okay
but then i realized with the hot tub
let's just say my eyes are more into a
hot tub than my body because it takes
it takes literally
seven hours to fill the tub up okay i
started the tub i went down to starbucks
i saw the seals
running water
you can
you it's giant you can you can i i would
say you have to you'll die of boredom if
you stay in the room
so then you fill the tub up i come back
with my starbucks i've gone ice skating
statistically there have been more
deaths of boredom at the edmonton hotel
than drownings so annie knows what she's
talking about i could have died from
drowning because i was so bored in the
hot tub too the minute i got in it after
all that work i was like it's really hot
i don't really want to be in here
i was in there for two minutes and then
i was like it's wet it's hot you sound
like an alien that you didn't know what
the hot tub would be like don't you
forget what it there's okay first of all
[ __ ] there's no way you don't hop into
a hot tub and go ill get me out
immediately you're read that but how
about what but who do you have working
you have carlos working now i'm a bath
technician oh you're right i have
questions for you then correct because
this is my gripe with
tubs in general yeah it's like actually
asian it's tripe because you put that in
your food okay
i
it's really hard to eat it's the chewy
like tenderness it's the entrails
oh wow and trails you're not intent
trails they really had to name it
something better then you better press
entrails yeah entrails but that's only
in english but tripa sounds good that's
right yeah
what is an entrail it's like uh the
intestines or the inside it looks like a
it's like a your body's netting it's
like so weird it's like so yeah and you
eat it
you eat it
i choose to have a taste here and then
yeah it's it's pretty good it's hard
though for me i'm not too into my my
theory is that if you kill an animal you
better [ __ ] eat every last inch of it
but okay you're great that's beyond my
gripe with a bathtub is this first it's
and i consider myself to be a mother of
dragons i can take high high high heat
like my showers are like scalding bobby
thinks i'm insane yeah so i like i like
to burn my skin the same house i think
it's a woman thing too how long are your
showers my showers are it depends how
cold it is outside
i take three showers a day i know it's
not good for the environment but like
there's something about being doused in
hot water that just really calms were
you a water birth
um i should have been but um my parents
sort of like threw me in the water when
i was two and i just learned to swim
that way but my thing is initially it's
really hot and i acknowledge the heat
but then within three minutes it's too
cold for me and then now i've just
wasted a [ __ ] ton of water and i'm
sitting how
like what do you do to stay warm in
there
do you just keep refilling after a
shower a bath oh my god of course i
refill so you just constantly keep the
hot water running yes i i love to get in
you
the best is when you get in and it's
like halfway full and it's really warm
but it's not hot yet and then you
haven't seen the oil yet come spread
and i will put some bath oil in i i'll
if i'm not washing my hair in the bath
water i'll put oil with the
fish though yes
i didn't wash my hair with
on
ducks that have been in a grease an oil
spill in an oil spill she literally has
to like that's who they advertise spca
and fema have to come together
to figure out what the best product is
for me oh esther you are a oily baby
duck yes so wait oh my god that's what
you are
don
that's the dish
listen bath technician
i this is my thing i do this is a trash
tank i could be this you guys could
license me out as a bath technician i'll
come over and give you both baths we
know you'll give us a bath ester why is
everything she pitches there's tits in
her face every
she sees someone's vagina in every pitch
is there a strip club are we talking
about in a strip club is there 70s music
while you're scrubbing us down i do want
to hear your 70s playlist so i am a bath
technician so the best thing halfway
it's very warm it's not hot yet you get
in and you get a little warm and then
you crank up that scalding hot water and
you [ __ ] cook yourself
this is probably why i had a miscarriage
it came out boiled
that's right it's not white i mean glad
you could laugh about it today and then
you know that's not why you're like i
know
why and then you know sometimes famously
my dad and i always talk about this
because when i was younger my dad would
be like you're making it too hot i i
know what you're doing in there you're
running cold water to cool it down
because you made it too hot so sometimes
you have to add cold water oh every time
every time i'm like okay my skin has
changed
but then there's too much of a lag for
the right temperature in a shower it's
immediate
it's like the flag is the fun of it so
you just sit there
this is like what you did instead of
watching tv as a kid
this is why she's never watched tv
i
cannot tell you how much water i wasted
in that giant jacuzzi i was it was two
minutes i was doing a meditation i
thought i was going to do my whole
hypnosis i ended up sitting
up on the mirror by the way they have
mirrors everywhere it's a total [ __ ]
palace
and a [ __ ] palace it is i mean it's like
where you're supposed to get banged out
and it was you and that guy josh it was
just potter everyone came with me i was
alone was he [ __ ] the bathtub it was
me
it was me and this jets
i did lose my virginity to a hot tub so
it felt good coming back wait were you
just um acting in solidarity with the
trapped seals in the mall i wanted to
[Laughter]
i was like randy are you here
i feel so guilty about this should we
like try to save the dolphins at the
mall
also is josh really blind he's going
blind yes
i'm trying to get him past the comedy
store before he goes blind but if he
does go blind we're just going to
pretend we put his name on the wall
everyone's already decided we're gonna
be like your name's on the wall how is
how is he performing in a garage like oh
look you're in the main room what does
he have that's making him go blind he
has i think he's your opener
he's gonna look at me a lot
listening and looking at me he's going
blind and deaf oh it's like a
degenerative thing like over time yeah
well his one eye went uh we should have
him on honestly he would be so good on
this but he has one eye
his good eye is the i that went when he
was young he was i think he was in like
seventh grade
i might not be getting the age right he
might have been 17 but there was a seven
involved i think
and he was just in class and all of a
sudden that was his good eye he he said
it was like a curtain got pulled over oh
[ __ ] and they just never saw out of that
eye again [ __ ] and then so he's been
since he was in high school he's been
using his
not that good and he plays video games
all the time and stuff too
but he has like all this anxiety all the
time he's cuz think about like because
i'm always like josh you're gonna be
fine he's like but imagine just one day
i'm just randomly fully disabled that's
right and like needs to count yeah i
know
but he's doing good he got health
insurance i love josh josh potter guys
josh potter show he's funny there's some
tragic stories involved but he's very
funny wow
he's the best he was saying he pitched
himself for if you ever can't come in
that he would show up and sleep over by
esther oh that's cute but we gotta get
the little shorties back
okay i'll make sure it's something real
good
you know um speaking of really really
hot baths they're in the middle i don't
know if this already exists or if
they're in the middle of a study to make
this exist but
once a month a man can dip his balls in
what's called a test called a hot bath
i'm sorry i thought we're trying to
immobilize his sperm as a form of birth
control
and where is this
i think they've done the studies in
europe or they're already doing this but
this is going to be an option for men in
the future where it's like it it
temporarily immobilizes the sperm so you
put your it's called a testicle bath and
you put you dip your balls it's a tea
bag it really is a tea bag yeah
and it's a separate yeah and i think
that's far less destructive than you
know what we have to go through for
decades of birth if it's an asian guy's
green tea
it sounds to me like a business idea
we have we have a
place that we you can come do that give
a take a testicle back we will sell you
we will sell you our bath water to dip
your testicles in then [ __ ] the girl
that actually will [ __ ] you
so you don't get her pregnant and don't
get her pregnant yeah well yeah that's a
thing like if you're trying to make
babies you're a guy is not supposed to
go in like a hot tub or take hot baths
because i think it it kills them off
right
i think that is the
the science behind it let me see i
wonder if that's like this the secret
from the playboy mansion like the grotto
they just all the guys just went in the
hot tub and then
look at this well so it's dyson that
makes it
dyson can't here's the layout dyson
can't stop
you dip your balls into this device
i just don't think that men would even
risk the idea of their sperm like it's
such an ego thing like my sperm needs to
move constantly wait carlos would you do
it
really yeah of course you would you're a
modern innovative man you're just always
kind of like raw dogging into these
girls almost getting them pregnant
[Laughter]
is that what you guys do on the road
i watch him [ __ ]
john
i watch him have condomless sex with a
woman
condomless sex
bareback anyone refer to sex as
condomless it's called bearbacking yes
sir oh boy it's called fun you know what
would be a good word on a scrabble board
is condomless that would be a that would
be a winning word
condom isn't there a hyphen in the
middle of condom
i don't know about i don't [ __ ] with
hyphens she's beyond my uh education
level well she's the health expert but
who is our grammar expert
dave let's just say it ain't me
yeah don't say
well gee
god gosh but at least you know how to
pronounce things i'm i'm that's where i
laugh you don't know how to pronounce
it's just maybe not in the right
direction
we don't even acknowledge
you guys mental health is pretty much
the only thing that matters to me this
year if you don't have your mental
health in check
goodbye
lit specifically to you by the time
i'll say this
if i were single and you were a guy and
you were trying to shoot your shot with
me if you're not i don't care if they're
sensible they don't care if you're
single they'll shoot single or not
single if you choose to shoot your shot
with me and you're not seeing a
therapist you are an immediate no
yes or other i need to see receipts that
you are actually actively working on
your mental health yeah because it's not
my job to fix it for you correct
check out betterhelp.com
trash tuesday betterhelp will assess
your needs and match you with your own
licensed professional therapist connect
in a safe and private online environment
it's so convenient and you can start
communicating in under 48 hours from
right now you can send a message to your
counselor anytime they have licensed
professional counselors who are
specialized in depression anger family
conflicts self-esteem for someone like
me i need to go to a therapist because
i'm about to rage out on carlos for
coughing during our well you also found
out something really traumatic during
this episode i'm definitely gonna need
so i'm going to be going uh better help
i'm coming to you a couple times this
week
i have some things in my notes in my
journal i'm ready to share with you
let's just say the discount code won't
work for annie anymore
anything you share is confidential and
we want you to start living a happier
life today as a listener you'll get 10
off your first month by visiting our
sponsor at betterhelp.com
trash tuesday join over one million
people have taken charge of their mental
health again that's betterhelphep.com
tuesday when you had to cut your hair
for the first season of doll face and
you were miserable and you're like we
all were miserable i really tried to
help and it was you know what you were
the best friend during that time because
you
didn't tell me i looked good you didn't
tell me i look bad you were like let's
make a joke out of this yes i was like
we'll write a joke it'll be fine it
really is the truth of being a comedian
we have a gift but hair is so important
and that's why i'm so glad we're
sponsored by nutrafull because i
actually learned about it from you
before they were our sponsor
and
you guys 30 million women are impacted
by weekend or thinning here and if
you're among them you're not alone and
there's a solution you can trust to
deliver results and i'm like a clip and
queen but the clip-ins pull your hair
out so you have to do both yeah when i
turned 30 my hair started to
um thin really really badly i'd always
been so used to having long luscious
hair that it was such a
a hit to my
self-esteem but when i started taking
neutrophil and i took it every day it
wasn't an overnight fix but in a couple
weeks i started to see oh those baby
hairs are starting to kind of grow and
then in months i was i got my full head
of hair back dude that is so inspiring
neutral offers two targeted formulas for
women that are clinically shown to
improve hair growth and thickness with
less shedding through all stages of life
you guys can grow thicker healthier hair
and support our show by going to
nutrafull.com
trash to save 15 off your first month
subscription this is their best offer
anywhere and it is only available to us
customers for a limited time plus free
shipping on every order get fifteen
dollars off at nutrafull.com spelled
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l dot com slash trash
so when i was at the mall i was like i'm
going to find like the right look
and then i finally went to super dry and
i was like i think it's got to be like
i'm a high school
girlfriend and then i'm like i'm your
girlfriend's for but then i realized
that's like it's like i'm why am i
dressing like a teenager that's kind of
gross okay let's talk about this because
this comes up for me a lot as a child
looking personal yes
because i know i brought this up like a
couple weeks ago like my sexy look
that would fit me best would not be
like a like i feel like either of you
could be like sexy dominatrix like for
me i feel like sexy school girl is like
all i have in my kids esther
it's really you just have made a choice
no no i honestly think like but i think
the internet would break like if you
wore like those squeaky leather pants i
have
like if you were in that outfit would it
be like insane i have an idea we're
going to prove your theory wrong you're
going to come in as a dom we're going to
come in as little like innocent school
girls and see if it works again i gotta
do another outfit
but no really go for the look that she
thinks only she likes oh i accidentally
talked them into dressing as sexy school
girl
she's like you can come over and borrow
some of my clothes i guess
i mean
i'll help you get them on i think
annie's right it is right i think you
could absolutely i think it's in your
head that you can't pull it off wait but
this is a weird thing that i i
cause why is it sexy schoolgirl white
panties let's just say that panties
started out white no
they've never ended white i told you
guys that guys this i hooked up with a
guy years ago who told me i'm not gonna
say whoever but who told me that i
should wear white panties because it's
like more in the line with the fantasy
it's virginal yeah
um
i get that but just to convene the
inconvenience of having a starkly white
panty at the end of the day looking down
something it's going to be something by
the end of the day but my point is it's
not going to be late
why kalila someone help me why it's just
that why do they like that why are why
why is the school girl like is it okay
that that's hot because it's literally
like you said it's like teens a fantasy
is a fantasy but even like french maid
it's like so you want me to look like
i'm working for you like
[Laughter]
so should we um resist or push back on
the idea that a fantasy
you leave the fantasies as fantasies
should we judge those fantasies like for
instance fantasy shame let's do a
segment called fantasy shame yeah that's
fantasy shame because like for instance
like i'm into
you know rape role play right but that's
a fantasy i really don't want to be
raped in real life i know i was like is
it a fantasy when it's happened to
somebody
you're right reenactment
so is there
there's nothing wrong with a guy being
attracted to a woman in a school girl
outfit because it's
not a child it's a a grown woman who
wants to be in this game pretty much
having the the conversation about
euphoria right it's pretty much we're
talk like it's almost the same thing
about that show right because i was
thinking about it last night did you
watch it no
well you watch it right yeah well it's
so much like and and the teens do not
look like teens in this one i feel like
they look older they look like yeah 25
which i think they cast on purpose i'm
assuming yeah yeah because there's all
these like hardcore teen [ __ ] scenes
where it's like
i just know my dad's watching i'm just
like oh god can i tell you something i
know every time i watch you for you i
think only about your dad i'm like uh
he's gonna like this scene there's
certain scenes i go my dad likes this
one
oh my dad is up late my mom's asleep
he's got his little like deaf man
headphones on my mom doesn't she can't
even hear the humping
is completely anonymous if she happens
to go stumble down for in her nightgown
for a snack she's going to see my dad
just silently watching two teens [ __ ]
bang each other
but it is weird because it's like
it's a weird thing but i don't want
there to be anything wrong with it like
i think you look hot is that bad like i
like this yeah you're a pedophile
she's not a cancer for instance i would
never judge a man on his
what he what kind of porn he chooses to
totally because that's just i feel like
a different part of the brain but you
could be not compatible with the porn
that they watch like
i i um hooked up with this guy on an
airplane years ago sorry todd
um
he fingered me on this airplane i met
this guy actually i can't believe i
haven't told the story on here i had
just missed an earlier flight and i was
coming to get another flight i was on
standby it was me and a guy in
army fatigues waiting for the one spot
left which i'm like they're obviously
giving it to the military guys i have no
shot but i'm just waiting there anyway
just like
and they go um all right it's like
they're about to close the doors and
they're like all right
sir gentlemen and i was like that was me
um but they i scored him on so i'm just
like the only one standing there like a
dildo i have no flight i'm just like oh
i guess i'll wait another six hours
and then the guy goes and they close the
door and then this guy comes running
with like two quiznos bags and he's like
he's like wait that's my plane
and they're like yeah but it takes off
and it goes yeah but it doesn't take off
until like 1205 and like it's 1205.
he's like but i made it they're like no
no it takes like he was like didn't know
that you had to get there early and i
started laughing because i was like oh
my god did you just miss your plane
because you were getting quiznos
that's so embarrassing i was just like
roasting him
and he was in sweatshorts which i have a
little bit of a thing for him wearing
sweatshirts really gray they were gray
and he had a one of these piercings
which is not a thing i'm usually into
but he just looked like he made bad
bad decisions
so i'm like making fun of him we go we
have to wait for the next plane together
so we're eating his shares his oh his
nose with me i just can't believe this
is going from a story of you hooking up
with a hot army guy to you and the
quiznos guy yes yes so i was like all
right i started to get hot i was like
this guy's kind of hot wait the quiznos
guys wait the same guy was starting to
get really hot the other guy was already
on the plane
so we're like talking and it just was
fun and then we went to go get our seats
and he took my id and he goes we're
together and he put our things together
and i was like
like i'm like oh i'm starting to get
like horny
and we get on the plane and he like
smelled good and he had a really good
body and he was like wait what city were
you in uh i think i was i think it was
atlanta i think it was my first
headlining weekend when i missed my
flight going out and then was playing
candy crush when i was leaving and then
fell asleep with my phone dead from
playing candy crush and slept through my
plane going home too
uh that was pretty epic
so that what was the the moment he got
hot was the id he was the idea was when
he got hot he shared his quiznos with me
which was nice too because that was
pretty expensive quizzes across the
entire flight he had two of them he did
but it was one it was like chips in one
bag like it wasn't it was like he just
had like he was just carrying it might
have been a drink too but he just had
like a sandwich what a sandwich with him
and then we're on the plane and he was
like he's like yeah i'm in a band and i
was like i don't care
and um but i you know i was like okay
and um he was like showing me pictures
of his band or whatever and i go what's
your band like and he was like it's kind
of like sugar ray and i was like that's
so weird you would say that
but i was like he was just like this
type of guy or whatever
and then he went to go to the bathroom
like i noticed he smelled good
and then he stood up to go to the
bathroom and his shirt lifted up a
little bit and i was like oh he has a
really good body
so he went and then when he came back we
just were like making out
in the seats yeah and my my drink was
like over like this behind the seat i
was in the window seat we were just
going at it and then
my drink was like hovering over this
woman's like excuse me and she had her
laptop my drink was just hovering over
her keyboard
and i mean where everyone was just like
a part of this whole experience there
was just this like israeli kid on the
end between us
are at the end not between us oh my god
that would have been so embarrassing i
got fingered over a child
but he had his little like mustache as
his little boy and his story fingering
over and then i had these jeggings and
he fingered me and then um and we were
like hooking up and then i remember we
got down to the
baggage claim and he kept trying to make
and i was like this does not go past
baggage claim this is i think he just
wrote my myspace rom-com
yeah
what were the jeggings and all we stayed
friends for a long time we did i like
stayed i used to like we would sext for
like years
and then because he found me i think on
facebook or something like he found me
after that because i was trying to be
like
we're done
um because i was like about to start
dating my
boyfriend that i dated at that time so i
was like i'm not gonna so then he would
be like in between boyfriend's guy i
would hit him up but when we started
sexting he started sending me like crazy
he was really into like bondage and
tying girls up and ball gags and stuff
and i was like we need a regular bang
before we even talk about this like i
was like i am not and it never happened
because i was like i'm not compatible
with what he he wants to literally like
like i don't want to get my [ __ ]
whipped i'm not interested in like no no
no leather things and that happened to
me
[ __ ] punch in a way i could do it yeah
it's like i've had it my pussy's been
thrown off okay it's cauliflower at this
point
cauliflower holly puss i got caulipus
but he yeah he sent me i actually used
to read it on stage
he eventually did get mad at me and
unfollow me but it was years that we
stayed what
what did he smell like that turned you
on it was just was it curve it was like
a fair amount like he definitely was
wearing something because he just was
you'll see what he looks like but he one
time
he sent me this whole thing where he was
like
pretend we're uh in high school we're
going to oh he doesn't look good there
find the hot pictures
not like fat now
there are pictures that you'll know what
i'm talking about yeah no i i believe
you'll know exactly what i'm talking
about no i can tell from you
deaf
is he dead did he daunting did he die
no i don't think so maybe that's just
like for the show that would have been
great for his life that would be very
sad but have you had a dead lover
no
i've had a lover yeah you [ __ ] them
death he was my brother
what oh yeah
oh
god this is this is a twisted tale of
it's flowers in the attic it's a little
bit of uh it's a dead poet's society you
know what it's valentine's day will you
remind us because i don't remember this
is her this is one of her i had sex with
my step-brother ella clueless hey annie
he did die oh is he dead yeah i found a
facebook post what did he die of well i
don't know that part but
annie i'm so sorry
well guys this is a different
turn i fingered him to death he fingered
me to death happy valentine's day he's a
nice guy that's sad he was a nice guy he
seemed to be pretty happy maybe a little
troubled figuring [ __ ] the way you
just described him made him sound like a
dream i am actually sad that he's i was
like sad when he got mad at me because i
i kind of thought i was going to keep
him forever even like
with todd i don't have any of those guys
still like i used to always kind of have
guys burner boys yeah they like [ __ ]
start you back in between back burner do
all hot girls have that i've never had
that rolodex for the oldies i've always
heard people say women they always have
the next guy lined up and i'm like i'm
no it's not that's not me i don't have
that guy lined up i have a guy that i
will never
date
but i have sexual chemistry with okay so
i hit up in between ease
yeah i wouldn't say lined up because i
think that there
there are about three men in my life who
constantly check in every year usually
around christmas time to see if i'm
single or not are you serious yeah this
is the kind of
are you we've heard them pick her calls
up they're like hello love of my life
sleeping getting crushed out of there
she's like is my [ __ ] nasty and like
you had the most beautiful [ __ ] ever
i was just dreaming about your [ __ ]
babe
[Laughter]
oh she's like aren't i disgusting
they're like no really honestly no one
measures up to you wait annie i'm so sad
this is sad i don't look like i'm like a
psycho this is no you're not
i also have another dead guy's story
that i was going to tell but i feel like
we need to let this one breathe a little
bit
it's trying he wrote me i wonder if he
died in like a ball gagging incident oh
i'm sorry well where is he annie's
he really took you
i i love the story you know from the
moment he took your id to you smelling
him
from the baggage claim to the grave
but you guys never had sex right no we
never [ __ ] because he started sending me
all of this like he sent me like the
porn he watched and it was like violent
i was like i'm was molested i don't want
this yeah it wasn't like it was just too
it also felt like cheesy it was very
like
red shoe diaries from the 90s it felt
like
there's a shirtless one oh yeah he looks
like he has a hot body he had all of
these like promo pics that were so fun
had i'm already speaking about him in
past tense we should have a funeral we
just bury a bunch of peanuts and those
that's what
no i think we should all find a quiz
nose oh my god this very quizno's wait
let's get a sponsor
wait let's turn this into us making
money somehow
no it's so weird
isn't it weird that like and i guess it
just happens throughout life but i do
feel like i'm getting to that age where
like there's so many daddies in my life
are you kidding me [ __ ] we're in comedy
it's about to go down all the old men
what did i say the other day
all the old men are dying around us or
something no i wrote it down esther for
some reason elderly men or esther's like
best it is she's so good at jokes about
old men no but i was like i was just
making a joke that like there's
something about being a comedian like
you
all your heroes are just old men who
want to rape you
i was thinking about this too it's like
all of my heroes have like great
grandkids now i'm like
and they're all like back in my day like
all the like male comics
back in my day we never nobody put their
penis into a vagina you're like why is
everyone talking about these things like
they're 900 years old we're just like
little young [ __ ] to them all i know
and then to the younger ones they're
like who are these old ladies they're
looking at us like are you guys about to
die
i have a surprise for you guys is it
that my
plane lover died
i'm gonna lift the mood of the room and
i'm gonna certainly lift annie's mood
but i need you to close your eyes real
quick
before this okay should we open our
mouths
is it you having a better outfit
we really thought you were gonna come in
like an angel
i dropped the ball okay not yet not yet
this is how i start my day
athletic greens yeah it's it's it's a
non-negotiable in my house it's a it's a
habit i formed immediately i love it
because it's
pretty good so with one delicious scoop
of athletic greens you're absorbing 75
high quality vitamins minerals whole
food source superfoods probiotics and
adaptogens to help you start your day
right this special blend of ingredients
supports your gut health your nervous
system your immune system your energy
recovery focus and aging basically all
the things and they come you have the
option to like i bring them when i
travel because they come in those little
packets yeah you just throw in your
backpack so i don't leave the house or i
don't leave town without my athletic
greens
yeah honestly and not to sound like a
slob but the thing that i love about
athletic greens is i take it in the
morning and then i'm like oh i already
got my vitamins and minerals i'm having
pizza for lunch yeah you don't have to
like chase salads all day exactly that's
exactly right yeah it's also uh
lifestyle friendly whether you eat keto
paleo vegan dairy free or gluten-free it
contains
less than one gram of sugar no gmos no
nasty chemicals or artificial anything
while still tasting so good it's
definitely worth trying um and right now
it's time to reclaim your health and arm
your immune system with convenient daily
nutrition especially heading into the
flu and cold season and it's just one
scoop in a cup of water every day that's
it no need for a million different pills
nope and supplements to look out for
your health it's just athletic greens
and to make it easy athletic greens is
going to give you a free one-year supply
of immune supporting vitamin d and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase all you have to do is
visit athleticgreens.com tuesday again
that is athleticgreens.com
tuesday to take ownership over your
health and pick up the ultimate daily
nutritional insurance
you guys after we did an ad for
girlfriend collective my mom called me
and was like so which items do you have
because i was looking at their site and
i'm like [ __ ] yeah why are you trying
to match me all the time
but i love girlfriend collective and you
guys
wide leg jeans chunky sneakers
everything old is new again right and
that's what girlfriend collective
literally means because they turn
plastic bottles and other waste that
would end up in a landfill into
something new to wear so i work out in
my girlfriend collective and i'm
literally wearing old water bottles and
it's soft and nice and i feel good about
myself i know i like when i'm wearing
literally the bottom of my car which is
i'm like cute outfits that also match
all of the trash on my floor
girlfriend collective creates
responsibly sourced activewear for
everyone from size extra small to 6xl
extra extra small
extra extra small
and what i love
about
i i feel more motivated to work out when
i know that i have cute workouts yeah
100 yeah i always start buying workout
clothes like six months before i start
working out for listeners of the show
girlfriend collective is offering 25 off
your first purchase of a hundred dollars
or more when you go to girlfriend.com
tuesday that's 25 off 100 or more when
you go to girlfriend.com
tuesday
girlfriend.com
tuesday
esther's being cute okay i'm ready
esther don't run your makeup with your
hands oh thanks i'm ready
oh they look so good on you
do you think they look okay they look
great
look at me
i already knew they look good on you
because i lent you mine and you looked
amazing in them uh the amount of sweat
that came out of every or like my
armpits when i had to hit apple pay with
apple what do you apple pay is that why
you say it
yes uh i was not feeling good about this
purchase but then when i got it i was
like oh perhaps they were don't you feel
like a queen in them yeah i do how did
you feel when you got your own celine
sunglasses that you spent an exorbitant
amount of money on did you
initially i felt pressured but then it
as soon as i put them on my face it felt
like
uh a necessity
because
you you guys know that i
i'm super conscious about like
masking and all of that so these are my
eye masks yeah these are my plain do not
[ __ ] with me i'm sleeping it covers so
much in my face that i love it you
taught me that concept of like
just cover your eyes like to hide you
know if you want to hide your emotions
or whatever you didn't put your makeup
on that day these are the perfect
glasses for that then why aren't you
wearing sunglasses more often that you
i've seen your makeup once this year
and i'm not talking about this i mean
last year
they look great here's what's going to
happen though this is what i chased the
feeling it felt to buy those because
there are no other
sunglasses and that is called a drug
addiction i'll just never get no i've
like bought them and had to return them
because i'm like they're not as good i'm
i literally it's just the feeling of how
good those were same guys are the best
ones
they came in two days guys i'll buy
where'd you order them from mine are
getting scratched up i'm ready to get
another pair you know what's so funny
like i do that sometimes like if i have
a pair of jordans i really like them
like i should get another pair by the
time i get that other pair i'm over the
style there's something about like
they have to run their course kind of
like that guy that fingers you on the
plane
dies live on your podcast live live to
tape what a reveal what a valentine's
day reveal i had another i had another
kid die on me that was really weird that
was a lover too
he was a potential lover
they died they escaped they're almost
[ __ ] me
i was um house sitting for this weekend
so i went to this is when hollywood
video and blockbuster and stuff were
around i went to a hollywood video to
get so many i was going to get the bach
the
all the seasons of the shield that was
what i was into the michael chiklis
michael chiklis which by the way i was
so obsessed with michael chiklis my
entire life because of the commish and
then that bobby is obsessed with michael
jackson i love him what's he up to we
got to get him on he was just on a movie
that i just saw
don't look up or it was something was he
in that no he wasn't in that one it was
some another big movie i was like oh my
god michael chiklis is in this also
don't look up because your glasses are
so heavy they will knock you back
it feels like they're worth the money
that you spend on them doesn't matter
like no other glasses have been like i
feel like i did it so i go to hollywood
video to get this box set i get the box
that while i'm in there i have my dog
punky was like a puppy i think she was
in my car i know my little munchkin my
daddy another daddy say hi to the guy
that fingered me on the plane
so for someone that figured me and
someone that ate me out to meet each
other finally is so good say hi to
kalila's dad and my grandparents and my
step-brother who i
oh god
and also this guy from a hollywood video
that i don't know
and do you guys know that my dad is
older than both anne frank and mlk
of course he is
of course
because i saw a post that we're like
anne frank and mlk would have been 93
today and i was like oh dear god you
inspired me to look up my what my how
old my grandparents would be and my
grandma on what a fun sport i know
this saturday would be my grandma's
108th birthday wow
around yeah so my 2 000 or mine was 1911
my grandfather really so my grandma was
born in 1914 i don't know
my grandfather might be around where
yeah those are the titanic years those
are fun years we're old sports the fun
years the titanic years yeah it's so
good we're not more autistic from all
that crest deals i think we have enough
autism between the three of us well i
mean when rick and i do get in the same
room it'll be interesting to see whose
fake autism is better
wait annie blockbuster hollywood video
thinking about blockbuster by the way i
know we do a blockbuster themed episode
it was just so fun it was such a fun
time in my childhood same [ __ ] it was
like you would go and just go through
all them and i was an event it was a
night out did you ever go through the
books you know blockbuster had the giant
book where you could look up movies and
they'd show you where they were and if
they had them i don't remember that i
was like this in the book i was friends
with all the people that worked there
that was the beginning of me talking to
strangers i just remember wanting to buy
the candy they're so bad the pickles and
my dad being like it's cheaper at
walgreens we have to go to walgreens i
was never allowed to buy candy at
blockbuster and he's gonna create quite
a monster and i like that
my spender
my precious spender we need to okay we
need the producers of the show to
recreate a blockbuster experience just
like how kalila wants to be raped again
i want to go to
to be clear
only if you are my lover and i trust you
yeah it's just like todd raping it's
like so unbelievable i'm like todd get
your noodles and to be clear todd can
you make me so why i don't want to be
choked i just want to be very clear that
i just compared my childhood trauma of
not being able to buy the candy i wanted
to your rape
i just want to be clear that is what i
did
and i am sorry but sometimes we have
different lives but and your
ex-boyfriend won't let you near his
house and delilah's are literally
waiting by their phone for her so we
have different things going on that's
true we all it checks it even we have a
restraining order and she has just guys
in order waiting for her to
restrain her because she loves here's
here's why they waited the phone for me
you tell them one good rape story in
your childhood and they want to take
care of you for the rest of your life
but then also i realized i did open with
them too much like i remember going on a
date with this guy and being like so
insulted he didn't want to date me and
when i think back on that date
i was
i was
rapping about rape i was just like
this is a story all about how my skirt
got flipped upside down
i'd like to take a minute
and sit right here and tell you how they
put pillows on the ground and set a
chair so they can focus carlos is
calling a banana oh i like that
we like when carlos takes charge yeah
unless we don't like it and then we're
really mad at him and then he's fired
[Music]
so i go into hollywood video i have my
dog in the car
he goes bring your dog in
he goes i'm the manager just bring your
dog in so my dog is running down the
aisles it's so fun i'm having a blast
punky was running around the aisles
having a great time this guy's so cute
he was like this cute little jewish boy
he was 21 i think i was 23. i thought he
was young i was like you're so young
todd was [ __ ] cut to totties and like
google queen
um
i love queen
every time i think about our age
difference
like before five years ago it's so
disgusting give it up girl
go asian guys um
dave
911 is my favorite because dave was an
adult working and living in new york
city and i was in sixth grade
i was in college that's so weird that
was my first year of college oh i'm
getting kind of turned out that's like
bobby and i so oh yeah bobby was what i
was doing
bobby was on mad tv and i wasn't um
i was a sophomore
wow
it is always crazy to think about
how long bobby has been successful human
being
no he'll never know he was even sadder
is that
like i'm asian i shouldn't be racist but
i also thought he played miss swan
i was like is that i couldn't tell that
it was alex borstein and i was like oh
my god he plays all of them including
miss swan kind of i like that she was
almost like a
hat of asians with swan was asian right
yes that wasn't a white person playing
an asian i don't know enough so i don't
know it is weird
you know like right now
there's a whole thing where you can't
cast someone if they're not that race
right whitewashing yeah i'm open to
being wrong
and nobody giving a [ __ ]
but why
do they always cast non-jewish people
yeah
cooperman was talking about this other
day too and it's like and no one gives a
[ __ ]
are you talking about marvelous mrs
maisel rachel brosnahan is lovely she's
literally so talented like i [ __ ] i'm
so she's so likable but like she won an
emmy for playing a jewish woman i know
she's not jewish and she's doing this
like wow she's like
hey guys i'm just a new yorker like girl
like she does it in like such like a jew
accent too it's like so racist tony
shalhoub is that
not jewish he's not jewish doing a
jewish thing i feel like he's the
winning awards nobody gives a [ __ ]
there's not one google there's no
articles nobody cares and there are so
many other examples
that i'm not thinking of because
i have a hot take
yes the hot take is
are the jewish people not the ones
casting
okay
interesting point and by the way that's
why i'm saying this might be a false
premise because like
maybe jewish people are so like
self-hating that like they're it's their
project and they don't want a jewish
star like i don't know but i think it's
i think it's weird yeah but also
jewish people literally we've had our
time they like jesus
it's okay like it's not the same as like
as scarlett johansson playing an asian
person
obviously that takes a priority do you
see that though a little
i want to see her playing the trans why
was she always the one playing the wrong
thing i have a question
a trans girl do you think that whoever
casts scarlet in that role was just
watching our podcast and they're like
scarlett
yeah that works
i mean it is yeah
i mean the whole thing's work because it
also is acting so you're like so the
whole argument is like okay because back
in the day it was like guys were playing
with all the girls too like in
shakespearean time
so it's like everyone's always been
playing right it's always changing so
then it's like
it's like is it weird if i play that i
live in boston and i know it's not the
same as race obviously but it's like
it's an interesting conversation
uh jamie lynn siegler played uh meadow
soprano what so that's the reverse of
jews playing uh no white man shut up i'm
just kidding why because she's jewish
playing italian
yeah is that okay
so that's like the reverse of what you
just talked about i just as as a as the
only brown person in this room yeah i
just want to say white wars white wars i
love it when white people fight yeah it
is all not even the race yeah it's not
even there's enough infighting in the
asian community we have it too but
really oh yeah well what are your what
are your thoughts on it are white wars
yeah like when you hear me say that are
you like okay white people like you're
fine shut up or any made a good point
what it's like you know so much of this
industry is like very you know
affluent and jewish right yeah
she's like
very rich they're rich too
yeah so it's almost like it lines the
pockets of the exact
type of person that is
miscast but that to me is a
an outdated thing of like will jews run
hollywood like to me that's almost like
the [ __ ]
i'm going off like names like legit like
it's like the the heads of the studio
harvey wants the harvey weinstein and
stuff i mean i don't know i'm i can't i
would have to look per project
i don't want to like just say that
that's the case wait what do you think
about um a non-gay person playing a gay
person or a gay person playing a
straight person i know because then it's
like is it okay for the gay person to
play the straight person but not the
other word because i think what a lot is
happening well it's because the gay
person is more is marginalized yeah like
they get less opportunities so it's more
important right then and like i guess
you could like jewish people are
are they marginalized i don't know like
you know
yeah kind of jewish people yeah yeah yes
but it's like it's like synagogue
shootings and [ __ ] it's crazy
it's kind of just like a weird sliver of
like no one wants us
but i asked someone that grew up in a
sea of jews and asians
it's so fun i actually like am living
out my middle school and high school
life with you guys i watch a lot of
hardcore jewish shows by the way
what's a hardcore
guys never watch it it's on netflix it's
one of my favorite shows never even
heard of watch every single episode of
guys so hot it's about um orthodox
um
jewish people living in um israel i
could see you being like an orthodox jew
chaser oh hardcore but they would never
go for me they would [ __ ] me but never
marry me it's really sad it breaks my
heart i thought jewish men are really
people
my whole life because one of my best
friends and like this
jewish guy i was like were dating for a
while but they were just more like
really lovers and he was like look i
really like you like in another world
like i would marry you but like i just
can't okay wait wait because to me i
feel like i'm like raised and like
thinking like
jewish men love asian women yeah like
they're like the super couple yeah it's
like korean jews.com like that is
something they very um similar like
sensibilities because like my my
one of my best friends is
very similar sensibilities but
um um alas like star-crossed lovers does
it end with
dave and bobby somehow snapping together
it's like west side story they're both
on other sides
but i am like
what is your opinion like do you is it
sound just like a white woman
complaining about jew casting like what
is your i'm not going to speak on your
side jewish people because that's not my
yeah i don't i don't know that
experience so like i'm looking at it
speaking out about this so it's not like
it's you're not like you didn't like
come up with an idea too it's like in
the zeitgeist to have these
conversations i don't think there's like
i think in a perfect world of course
everyone would play according to i mean
all characters will be played to the
specificity of the story and the world
and the culture right but
is that something that is feasible 100
of the time moving forward i also feel
like it's like if people choose to make
that their fight that's their fight i'm
like just trying to like have a good
time and that's not my [ __ ] crazy do
you know what i mean same girl like i
support anyone wants to fight them it's
like i'm gonna just really every day
wake up and be like let's make this a
good one let's just try to get you know
how many hypnosis hypnosis things i had
to listen to today because i woke up
just with the darkness inside me and i
was like not today [ __ ] i'm not dead i
know i know i've had the darkness inside
me i think i've given myself i think i
have another stomach ulcer annie i'm
going to send you this one hypnosis from
my mary lou rodriguez guys check her out
but for anyone watching please watch
diesel okay i really love this show and
i feel like i'm the only one that's
watching we're just happy you're not
watching only cartoons
there's a really good one no but i know
it's adult cartoons but it's like you're
masturbating to them let's be real um
s
h
t i s e l i think okay schtiesel okay i
don't know how to pronounce me either do
you know that the number one um porn
people watched on pornhub all year this
last year was anime porn i don't
remember penta yeah yeah
we gotta get back out in the world
because it's people are [ __ ] octopus
they're [ __ ] octopus octopi octopuses
but that's hentai no hentai is anything
it's robots it's everything it's like
the extreme but it's a lot of
penetration like hardcore like
transformers
time sex this one that's the transport
people are into this is still my
favorite show of all time that's the guy
i think it's so hot that's he's so hot
oh my god you guys these are so hot hot
it's just so funny that that's what you
led with
he is hot thank you esther
yeah i gotta see without the bangs i
don't even mind the side curls it's the
bangs that i'm having trouble my
filipino mom this is her favorite show
too we watch it together
he's so hot to me i can't even look you
guys
i love jesus jewish men are hot as [ __ ]
i do like a strong i've only like strong
noses and what i love about todd is his
nose is like kind of wide like he has a
i love his nose i love a wide ramen i
love a big nose because i like a junos
the most like i do like one that comes
out it's like it almost is incestuous
because it kind of reminds me of my
brother's noses i guess
well my brothers have like my twin
brother max he broke his nose so many
times and his nose looks like shapes
were like shoved up like blocks were
shoved up like there's all these shapes
going and then timmy got a nose my older
brother got into his job he did yeah why
i have a question
oh by the way yeah your brothers are hot
it's kind of weird
it's so confusing i think they look
regular like they have hot wives which
is a good sign
you know right because you have no way
of telling if they're actually hot yeah
i'm like i think because
i mean their their noses were made fun
of a lot in our household
a lot really my dad's
my dad when people would come up to me
like your kids are cute
my dad would go um wait till their nose
is growing i love you dad
i love you that okay we did a photo
shoot
with i was working in santa fe thank you
so cute in santa fe i was working for a
photographer
you are so cute i was thinking i was
yeah
i was thinking that i was like there are
pictures i can show you as a child where
like you would want to go back in time
and molest me i was
i think i really have to look at this
like i really am a chosen one i was
blessed i was a beautiful baby but so we
i worked with this wedding photographer
and max came into town to santa fe one
day and she's like let me take pictures
of you so we actually got like
engagement yeah these are romantic
they're so romantic you need this isn't
that so crazy like we look like we're
like about to like make it official that
is the way he's looking at you
is literally hasn't looked at me since
but wait now i feel like your brother
looks like todd he doesn't look like
todd at all there's like ruining it but
i do call todd
i do call but i but he does feel like he
could be in my family every time i'm in
love with someone like truly like the
fire burning inside me love which has
only been twice
i have weird moments where my body like
like short like i like the matrix breaks
and they look like they're in my family
like i know it's sick the other
annie this is true do you know what i'm
talking about it was like i just saw
like a male version of my sister and it
was really kind of
rough i accidentally called todd mom
sometimes
like i am so in love with this person
that i'm like you may as well be my
mother like i am like he's just like in
my fam he's mine like he's my people
it's so weird and it sounds very
unromantic but i swear to god it's like
a weird it does not sound unromantic to
me like i accidentally like and he's
like
i like have to explain i'm like it's not
out of any sort of like not attraction
thing it's like i like i'm so into you
that i i just love him i just say the
things that i love speaking of noses um
i so i have um total nasal collapse on
both so when i breathe in no air has
come through my nose for a couple years
wait are you serious i can't i'm a mouth
breather
and those juicy lips you see it yeah so
i can't breathe because i struggle
breathing through my nose too
so i went to a dog i guess we have so
much in common like maybe it's gonna be
hard when you guys are 69
choking on each other do you know how
hard blow jobs are for me because i
can't um nose breathe it's really and
you do not want to suck in too much
stuff this is why i want to be facebook
because i'm just like honestly it's it's
it's a life or death situation sometimes
when i get face [ __ ] i'm like there's no
air coming in my nose like i am like you
got to give me every 30 seconds get give
me a breath but anyways so i went to a
doctor um in november
that is so funny that needs to be
clipped out
this is why i'm like to facebook i got a
phone call during it spam risk
you answer i was like hello this has got
to be more important than this my
question to you guys is this so
apparently they have to put a graft in
to keep my valves open do they have to
break it like nose jobs i don't know
what they have timmy had a diva accepted
my brother that's why he got the nose
job and they gave him a full like it was
like a full rhinoplasty because they
were already gonna have to do it so they
have to like but yours sounds like it's
not obstructed it just crashes in fact i
don't have a deviated septum i just just
collapsed
and apparently this happens to a lot of
women when they have hormonal changes
like over the years i'm like why didn't
i have this as a kid and they were like
sometimes do i have it
a lot
go breathe in it should close
nope yours don't collapse i like how you
have ailment fomo
if or when i do get my nasal valve thing
it's going to look like a rhinoplasty do
i not do i hide the fact or do i just
come in look i got my valves come on
listen you come in but don't be taking
it off and all of a sudden you got a
little the tiniest little button nose
and you're trying to play it off i like
my prominence doesn't it sound like
she's but doesn't it sound like she's
like planting seeds to get like a
full-blown nose job
should i come in when i have to get this
like surgery that's like so
serious i can't breathe it's life risk
next week i i'm like so my boobs are
gonna be looking weird
the only way to prove that it is not in
fact the rhinoplasty is that my
insurance is fully paying for it oh wow
so they're like yeah
so that's how we know it's not a
rhinoplasty or it's a scam of a lifetime
healthy baby
baby but i'm just gonna be like every la
girl with a bruised nose with a
rhinoplasty look right so cool i
remember you're gonna what we should do
we'll come in with those pore strips
that day yeah to look like i have to
wear those every night just to breathe
because if i accidentally close my mouth
in my sleep and i um
i wake up like i can't breathe i might
die oh my god i'm gonna have to get one
of the nose sleep apnea masks those are
the craziest ones just go right here
yes because i cl nothing comes through
right so when i so this is what i tell
bobby to do like if he sees me sleeping
he has to do this am i good
he has to pry my mouth open you're
counting on bobby lee to keep you alive
at night well i could see him watching
her sleep that doesn't seem that off
he's playing video games and then just
stares at you he does do that he does
like rub my back and like tuck me in and
stuff sweetie pie he's in rehab right
now shout out babe
okay what is the game today
uh we have dice okay i'm gonna what so
what happens i roll my dice and then
what
yours are gonna be telling
whoever you want where to
kiss you or do whatever to you
okay no i'll throw it on the floor i'll
be fair and square big money big money
someone has to suck my thigh again oh my
god
she's all nervous she's doing the just
kidding
do you want to make out just kidding
unless you're into it
that's so sad are we just friends no i
mean i'm just kidding i was just kidding
it's a joke
what are the other options
okay i'll do this with todd
the kitchen gentle kitchen and then
kalas are the positions gentle in the
kitchen
i'd rather do a library with a
candlestick
you have to suck my thigh gently in the
kitchen and now sucking your thigh
gently is we do so much we do have a
kitchen i know let's roll let's see what
you got okay hang on so what's mine
carlos uh postures postures and
positions
um one is oh
backwards
this is weird
okay so legs up in the air missionary
and reverse cowgirl
oh those are the two options like
straight up missionary but my favorite
esther get in there are we supposed to
oh
astra doesn't want to stand up because
there's going to be a little wet spot on
her that's not true on her little dress
i'm going home she's nervous she's just
creating one sexual act so this is the
gentle yeah suck
now lester's like only concerned and her
heart's getting good i'm mean you guys i
feel like i'm i'm the only one playing
this game that's true what's the other
one let me see the other one lick navel
oh god there's so much lint in there i
know it's really crusty well someone
should do it for esther the navel esther
wants she's going to give you a raise
for this one
that's crazy he's really looking out for
you
why are you fingering yourself what are
you doing scratching your vagina my leg
zoom in it's my leg
zoom out
let's try again
kiss navel
again here
i'll kiss your [ __ ] navel
get in here sir wait you're wearing a
dress you got to lift your dress oh god
i can't wait to see this under where she
picked of course oh the hair i have that
too
oh she doesn't have that she was being
nice
thank you every episode is just so
highly when you met olivia munn for the
first time and you had pubes down to
your knees that was the greatest thing
i've ever seen wait i don't remember
that
it whitney was like come over we're
having people over and it was like it
was the day taylor thomas and bro
scratched her leg on the edge yes the
point they put her on like a decorative
egg it was like a like a
like it may as well have been like
macrame it was like the lightest thing
and she was like stand on this and
taylor just got her legs sliced open oh
my god
and whitney was like we got it on camera
[Laughter]
um but that day whitney was like we'll
go to the pool so she just gave us all
swimsuits and stuff and then
we did a photo shoot and
let's just say there were long sleeves
on esther's
swimsuit but there were not
on her
bottom unfortunately i guess
that's why
i'm trying to get x-rated so i'm in
hollywood
my video running around and it's gonna
be a tv container this guy is like so
cute so awesome and he goes
he's like we should take our dogs to the
dog park because when you're done house
sitting like let's go to the there's
this beautiful arboretum the curtis
arboretum i was like this is like the
greatest date i could ever imagine i was
like okay i was like hell yeah gives me
or i give him my number and like call me
in like two days he doesn't call me so i
go to the hollywood video and i'm like
hey is alex working
and they both like look at each other
and they're like should we tell her
and i went what and they went oh he died
the other day
overdose with like my [ __ ] number in
his pocket
annie and they didn't want to tell you
well it's weird they were like uh but
also i was thinking like wouldn't it be
funny if he was like hiding under the
desk
just because i died
what did we learn today esther
wow
well we have a funeral to plan and
that's going to be hard but we're going
to do it we're going to bury some
quizzes we're
going to get sponsored by quiznos do
do quiznos still exist
oh my god we're more sad about quiznos
we all cry we need a blockbuster themed
episode yes we need to immobilize carlos
um semen with a testicle bath yes
how are we gonna test that two quiznos
we tell them to go have sex with a girl
and see if she gets pregnant
that's probably one of us
just turkey-based one of us and see if
one of us gets pregnant i believe you
have very very hyper mobile
um 89 mile per hour sperm sperm yeah why
you're athletic he just has to like that
fr he's
carlos looks like he has a big dick
that's his body shape
guys that look like carlos always have
big dicks but you cannot tell a dick
from a body i can't why are you arguing
i can carlos
[Music]
oh esther was there for it just that
they liked my dedicated cam on the show
i will say on the road carlos's boner
comes up a lot yeah kalila you get
brought up all the time to me on the
from the stage um after the shows people
are like brother how did you not get
hard
better not those better not be black
people that you just did no no no
southern guy we were in nashville
yesterday
but also that's a shock to me to my ego
really no it's not because they're like
people they're like what is it no
they're not like they can't believe salt
water in your presence that someone
would not be hard
i know right i'm i'm on their side i
think
i had 30 seconds to prepare i know i
know i know but carlos i truly think
that you secretly have the biggest dick
in the world in the room
i've seen
i know you sent it to bobby but we all
looked at it as a team is that why
you're called the pink whatever yeah the
pink thing afterwards
it's big and pink
happy valentine's day to my beautiful
happy galentine's day oh
that's the gallon of gogo originally
from parks and rec written dave was the
writer of that show so you can take it
so it's ours now
you guys thank you so much as you know
we're trying to get to 200k subscribers
this is the next week okay please
subscribe if you haven't yet comment if
you like our theme ideas
and
what else
yeah i'll keep interrupting sorry guys
it's not gonna stop we're three old
sperms and we'll see you [ __ ] next
week bye guys bye guys
[Music]
you